we're starting today with the topic of
abortion and this is a topic that there
was a period of time where it was less
of an issue there was less of a question
as to whether roe v wade was going to
remain the law of the land but now with
the supreme court potentially just weeks
away from issuing a ruling that would
uphold state restrictions on abortion
which would effectively reverse roe v
wade and the undue burden standard that
roe v wade contains which we will get to
that we are seen
expectedly as predicted more and more
states pass the types of laws that we
have seen from mississippi and from
texas and from elsewhere and the latest
state to do this is now oklahoma
oklahoma lawmakers have passed a
six-week abortion band a ban
modeled after the texas law that allows
civil enforcement that's another element
of this that is wacky retrograde stuff
civil enforcement of this law
and we will talk about why a six-week
abortion ban is effectively just a ban
on abortion
which unquestionably would violate roe v
wade's undue burden clause
except roe v wade may be reversed so
let's read about this first associated
press reporting oklahoma lawmakers
thursday gave final approval to a bill
modeled after the controversial texas
abortion law we knew every state that
wants to ban abortion is going to start
using that type of
the the they will use each other as
models
it is a
law which allows private citizens to
take civil action against abortion
providers as individuals to enforce the
law
it's a sort of vigilantism in practice
the oklahoma heartbeat bill uh heartbeat
act senate bill 1503 would prohibit
abortions at the time when a physician
can detect early cardiac activity in an
embryo or fetus now understand that it
is not
it is
some like to say it is a heartbeat and
doctors often say
it's this is reflexive cardiac activity
to call it a heartbeat isn't even
accurate uh that can be as early as six
weeks into pregnancy before many women
even know they are pregnant
the measure also provides exceptions for
medical emergencies the state senate
later thursday also passed house bill
4327
allowing private citizens to sue
abortion providers house bill 4327
however would prohibit abortions at any
point of pregnancy with exceptions for
medical emergencies or if the pregnancy
comes as the result of rape sexual
assault uh incest and is reported to law
enforcement so there's two parts of this
first we've already talked because of
the texas bill about this ability for an
individual to sue the abortion provider
it's another way to put in this case
it's not only the government between
doctors and their patients but random
people between doctors and their
patients if anybody can bring a civil
suit
but i want to focus in on the six six
week ban thing because the defenders of
this bill who want to at least pretend
about the rule of law which is roe v
wade established that generally speaking
women should have access to abortion
services and that no undue burden should
be placed on them in order to obtain one
now undue burden is a legal term that's
subject to interpretation and this is
where
i mean for 40 years that that phrase
undue burden has been subject to
interpretation by courts at all levels
but a six-week ban would absolutely
violate that and just think it through
many women most women don't know that
they're pregnant until four to five
weeks and what i mean by that is by the
time you miss a period and by the time
most home pregnancy tests can detect a
pregnancy
you're already considered to be four
or five weeks pregnant at minimum if you
at that point were to say hey
uh i got a positive pregnancy test i'm
going to go to my uh doctor my ob gyn
they will say oh yeah it's not you're
pregnant and it's the first week they
would say you are practically speaking
for potentially five weeks pregnant at
this point of time and and if that if
the requirement is no abortions after
six weeks
what that means is you need to say oh
well i need an abortion like tomorrow
and of course that is unreasonable that
is an undue burden even if one can
decide that quickly
to
if if most of you have tried to get
medical appointments lately you might
know you don't call and they don't give
you an appointment for tomorrow that's
generally a difficult thing to do so in
practical terms this is designed to be a
total abortion ban and it effectively
would be
by enforcing the six-week rule um we
will see
what happens in the supreme court this
bill this law will be appealed
based on current law it would be found
against roe v wade it would place an
undue burden on women you can't say six
week ban most women don't find out till
week four or five if they're pregnant
right so right now it would not it would
violate roe v wade
if in a few weeks
the supreme court says well
we're okay with this law and i believe
it's mississippi
that would effectively overturn roe v
wade and that would make it so that laws
like this one in oklahoma and the one in
texas and others
likely would be allowed and uh of course
this then gets us into that situation
where what happens do people start
fleeing red states for blue states or
what is the right thing to do what is
the expected thing to do we don't know
yet but this is exactly what we do
go back to the beginning go back to my
shows
when i was saying hey you know guys i'm
worried this is this is 2016.
i'm worried
that there's too many people who aren't
taking seriously this issue of the
supreme court when they think about
trump versus hillary they go wow i don't
know if it's not going to be this person
if it's not going to be that person
hillary trump it's all the same and i
would say folks
you have no idea what a few conservative
supreme court picks by trump would do to
this country
the first thing they will do is they
they are going to try to ban abortion
and then trump got one pick and then he
got a second pick and then he got a
third pick and then we knew they're
going to start the state level bills the
point of those bills is that they be
appealed all the way up to the supreme
court and the supreme court might say no
on the first one
they might say no on the second one they
might not like some specific aspect of
the third one
but if they do it enough
with this right-wing court thanks to
trump defeating hillary and we have to
be honest that that's what put us in
this position
uh they may well overturn roe v wade we
may be weeks from the end of roe v wade
one of our sponsors today is blue
bluechew a unique online service
delivering the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis in a chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost and
they're giving my audience an entire
month supply for free so if you think
you could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping